brief announcement some people requested
to talk on a one-hour monthly group call
either asking questions or presenting
their ideas to me slash others so a
patreon tier has been opened up for that
purpose the first call will be limited
to around 10 people and it will be june
1st 2022 for the meta field theorist
tier that's patreon.com kurt jymungal
as with all podcasts you can click on
the timestamp in the description or over
here you can see the timestamp to skip
this intro
lillian dindo is a professor of
psychiatry at the baylor college school
of medicine and a researcher as well as
popularizer of the psychotherapeutic
technique or way of life depending on
how you look at it called acceptance and
commitment therapy which we call act
therapy if you've watched the recent
carl fristen episode which is linked in
the description then you'll see that i
consider that one to be the most
important episode of all the theories of
everything podcasts and that's in
particular because it serves as a
cautionary tale of what serious
examinations into consciousness and
reality altering theories can cause in
one's mind and it's not pleasant you may
have heard me use the term abignosis
which is what i think science will
develop to merging the inwardly
experiential knowledges with the
outwardly objective knowledges broadly
speaking on the toe podcast one of the
eventual goals is to take a syncretic
approach to both the east and the west
which are ordinarily kept separate what
i like about lily and dindo is that the
act therapy that she advocates for not
only helped me during recent extreme
psychological turmoil but simultaneously
it serves as a bridge between the
philosophies of the east and the
practices of the west now if you're
interested in the philosophies of the
west and the practices of the east then
you can watch the recent ahl mass
episode linked in the description as
well my name is kurt jaymungal and i'm a
filmmaker
podcaster slash person investigating
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as understanding the philosophies
of consciousness and what role
consciousness has to fundamental reality
recently there's been a video released
on this channel called a crash course on
theoretical physics which was the
longest time that i've spent on any
single video on this channel if you're
interested in salvator pius's ideas on
quantum gravity or extra dimensions or
what it means when a physicist
quote-unquote sets c to equal one to
equal h-bar then do consider watching
that as it's the lesson that i wish i
had when i was going to university by
the way my background is in mathematical
physics and the math in this video is
aimed at the high school level there are
plenty of myths in physics that are
dispelled there as well as well as
general tips on learning mathematics and
physics feel free to share that to
someone who's interested in physics and
mathematics this work was only able to
be done because of brilliant and the
patrons now with regard to brilliant
they're the sponsor of this episode
brilliant is a website and an app that
has interactive learning experiences
with regard to math science and
engineering they have lessons on
information theory on group theory and
special relativity group theory by the
way is what's being referenced when you
hear that the standard models
quote-unquote internal gauge symmetries
are u1 cross su 2 crosses su 3 and so on
at some point soon i'll be speaking to
chiara marletto on constructor theory
and that is heavily predicated on
information theory and so i took
brilliance course and it made it
extremely lucid why the formula for
entropy is the way that it is visit
brilliant.org toe to get 20 off the
annual subscription i recommend you
don't stop before at least four lessons
and i think you'll be greatly surprised
at the ease at which you now can
comprehend subjects you previously had a
difficult time grocking now if you enjoy
witnessing and engaging in real time
conversation with others on the topics
of consciousness psychology physics
religion then check out the description
for a link to the theories of everything
discord and subreddit there's also a
link to the patreon that is
patreon.com if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reason that i'm
able to put out videos of this quality
and this depth such as the crash course
on theoretical physics as this is what
i'm now able to do full time thanks to
your support
thank you and enjoy professor one of the
reasons i was and am excited to speak
with you
is because when one goes about this
project of questioning what reality is
and consciousness and so on which is
essentially what concerns this channel
it can be destabilizing there can be
existential dread and what i found that
helped me was something called act
therapy an approach called act and i was
searching for more information about it
a few months ago and your name kept
popping up over and over and since then
i think i've watched all of the material
that has you online
so i'm super excited to speak with you
about act and why don't you start off
with what is act what does it stand for
what is it and how did you become
interested in it
okay
um
so act is stands for acceptance and
commitment therapy
and
act as a psychological treatment
approach it evolved out of the
behavioral analytic tradition
and it focuses on teaching skills for
living effectively even in difficult
circumstances
so act actually is more than just a
therapy it's a framework for living well
and unlike a lot of treatment approaches
or protocols that are tied to specific
symptom presentations or disorders
act is actually applicable to virtually
all people
regardless of circumstances culture
complaint
and i think part of the reason for that
is the premise from which it begins so
act begins
with this fundamental understanding
that pain
grief
loss disappointment
fear these are inevitable features of
living a human
life and
no one escapes it and so the goal of act
is not the elimination
of these experiences or symptoms
but instead
a wholehearted pursuit
of living a valued life
valued life areas like relationships
meaningful work
education personal growth
even in the presence of difficult
emotional experiences and thoughts
so the emphasis and the heart of act is
creating this life
um a worthwhile life that you want both
now and in the future
so
act you know doesn't believe that people
are broken or that they have illnesses
just that they're stuck in
understandable patterns that aren't
working for them based on
their history what they've been through
and so act gives people the tools to
deal with
the opportunities and the difficulties
that life throws our way
um
and in a
nutshell it helps us accept things that
are really difficult to control and
teaches us to commit to doing the things
that we deeply care about
so in a nutshell
that's that's what act has
you know um
is about and
i got into it when i was in graduate
school and i had learned you know all
these other models of therapy
and to be perfectly honest i wasn't
for example traditional cognitive
behavioral therapy um interpersonal
psychotherapy
and
they were fine they were great you know
but it didn't personally resonate with
me you know it was like i'm the expert
and i'm going to treat this person in
front of me using this intervention
and i remember opening up
you know starting to study act and
opening up the book
you know for for the class and
there was this sentence in the first
paragraph of the
main act textbook
and that
the end of that paragraph said
the single most remarkable fact of human
existence
is how hard it is for human beings to be
happy that sounds extremely eastern is
this influenced by eastern approaches
it's absolutely
so the other thing it says is suffering
is a basic characteristic of human life
um and it's absolutely influenced by
eastern philosophy so it has you know
there are six processes in act
and again unlike other treatment
approaches it was built from the bottom
up and so
there were lots of clinical
science studies being done even before
act was presented as a treatment model
and so it pulled from things that were
found to be effective and from the
eastern tradition for example we know
that mindfulness is effective
um and that this basic premise that
suffering is
you know
a part of the human condition and so
act certainly has parts of the eastern
tradition but it's not only that
act as an exposure therapy but it's not
just an exposure therapy
act as a behavioral activation therapy
but it's not just a behavioral
activation therapy it pulls in
different processes that have been shown
to work
over time and puts them into a treatment
package
is it fairly new
it is not fairly new um the first
textbook
description of act came out in 1999
so act as a package came out in 1999 but
the developers of act had been
researching
for about 20 years beforehand the
different processes like
you know
thought suppression you know we known we
we know one of the most consistent
findings in psychology which is hard to
find
is that thought suppression even though
it works really well in the short term
it actually leads to a rebound effect
in the long term you know so trying to
push down thoughts trying to distract
from thoughts trying to run away from
thoughts
very effective in the short term but in
the long term actually has a rebound
effect
so the developers of act had been
researching these processes for a few
decades before they came out with the
treatment model in 1999.
between 1999 and now the research
literature on act has completely
exploded
there are over 300 randomized control
trials right now of act
and in general a recent meta-analysis of
the meta-analyses
has shown
that it's either equivalent to other
gold standard treatments
or in some cases can be more effective
more effective
and
enduring
what are some of these understandable
difficulties you mentioned earlier that
people go through so i imagine one may
be obsessive thoughts what are some
other examples of illnesses or
if one doesn't want to consider them
illnesses or whatever you would like to
call them what are some examples of
distresses that people go through that
act seems uniquely equipped to handle
um
i mean again back to just living a human
life i mean
everyone who's
got a pulse is going to be rejected at
some point no matter how
wonderful and and intelligent and
beautiful and successful you might be
you're still going to be rejected by
people in your life you know and that's
going to hurt
we're all going to have an illness in
our life we're all going to face
a medical illness that's going to
challenge us we are all going to face
heartbreak uh the loss of people we love
in anything that you care about there's
the flip side that it comes with pain
if you have a child you know
that
you love that child deeply you care for
that child but with that love
comes intense anxiety about their
well-being and their health and their
future right
and so in act they have this saying in
your pain
you find your values
and in your values you find your pain
and that means that anything you care
about if you care about a friend
and you care about a friendship and
you're betrayed
right and so
the natural thing like let's take that
for an example you have a friend really
good close friend
and you were betrayed or you felt
rejected
the easy thing to do would be to
withdraw not talk about it withdraw shut
them out of your life right
and you can also avoid future
friendships
for example because you feel like you've
been rejected and you've been
you know you don't trust and so
it applies to any of life's difficulties
you know going to grad school you have
to be
going to any actually you know
educational
program it's not easy
you have to face criticism you have to
face difficult challenges how do you
face those challenges
do you withdraw or do you face them
so when you ask me like what are the
challenges
i think
there's really far reaching it's
anything in life that
is gonna gonna hurt sometimes
and also opportunities you know when
someone says to me like you just said to
me will you come
do this interview
it would really be much easier and less
anxiety provoking to say no thank you
right much easier
but over time if i keep doing that
number one i never learn how to cope
with my anxiety
number two my anxiety starts actually
seeping into other areas because i never
learned how to cope with it
and number three
my world's getting smaller because i'm
not doing something i care about
this latter part sounds like the
exposure therapy aspect but if you were
to avoid it well that's going to make it
worse and if you were to encounter it
voluntarily slowly incrementally on your
terms then it increases your resilience
so are you feeling anxiety right now
i'm definitely feeling anxiety right now
um
my heart like so what is anxiety right
and if you disentangle anxiety what is
it
any emotion has three components it has
the physical
the physical experience so right now
like my heart's definitely racing a
little bit more than maybe the norm
i can feel my throat like a little bit
constricted you know i feel a little bit
shaky
so those are the physical sensations
right
then there's the thoughts
now
right now i'm focused on you so you know
there aren't a lot of thoughts going on
but in general like the thoughts are
like before i came in
oh my god am i to know how to answer
this is i have to blow this am i going
to sound stupid right i mean it's
these are the thoughts
and then the third piece is
the behavioral like urge that you have
that comes with an emotion
you know that's a component of the
emotion and when it's anxiety the
behavioral urge is to run
right it's to say
not gonna do this because if i run
in the short term
my anxiety goes down
right
so
what i've learned to do
and i've had panic attacks by the way
and i learned and i you know i've run
away many times um
but what i've learned to do is when i
notice my anxiety well let me ask you
this kurt let's say that i noticed my
heart racing and my throat constricting
and i start saying to myself
this is terrible
you cannot do this this is terrible this
is the worst thing this is awful why am
i like this why after 20 years do i
still
get this way it's so ridiculous get with
it
what do you think will happen to my
anxiety
it won't go away it may increase and
especially if you leave in that
situation once it'll make it much more
likely for you to leave again and so
avoidance will increase as well
both yes so actually if i respond
to the physical sensations
with
rejection and why and this is awful
then it actually increases the anxiety
so now when i notice my heart racing and
my throat constricting i say okay
your heart's racing okay your throat's
constricting
and this is important like this is
important for me to do so
you know i can be with this that's the
value part
exactly it's you connect it the values
piece is what makes it worthwhile like
why would i put myself in this situation
well i'll put myself in this situation
because it matters to me because this is
something i care about you know
so it provides the motivation it
provides the why for why i should do
this values are
the purpose behind
why you might do things that are
uncomfortable or difficult so
there's number one
you know just noticing my okay like my
heart's racing okay
that's okay you know my throats go okay
my throat's constricting that happens
when
i go running that happens
in many situations
but sometimes i interpret it as
dangerous and sometimes i interpret it
as pleasant
but the physical sensation itself is the
same
and so
it's like now i can say okay i'm okay i
can i can have this anxiety and still
commit to doing this because it matters
to me
is it exactly the physiologically the
same so i hear this plenty that people
will say excitement and anxiety are two
sides of the same coin except it depends
on the interpretation you place on it
one is positive but i don't know is that
actually true if one was to examine all
of the biomarkers could one in a blinded
study determine dispassionately this
actually this person's going through an
anxious emotion whereas this one's going
through an excited emotion
crazily
yes
they're the same
there's this um and i you might want to
cut this off from the video
sure sure
you might want to cut this off but
anyways there's a there's a study
um by some famous sex therapists and
they
did a biomarker study actually
where they hooked up people who were
you know like um blood
you know
electrodermal response heart rate few
other biomarkers and they found that the
biomarkers were exactly the same or
similar enough i guess so that's
statistically significant
that people having an orgasm were
indistinguishable from people having a
panic attack
right so well that's extremely
interesting
right and so you know the heart racing
throat constricting like feeling like
whoa right like
they were indistinguishable
on the electrode response and on the
heart rate and and other biomarkers
so
so yeah in a lot of ways they're not
distinguishable actually
okay now
in a meta manner we've gotten to the why
of act that is why should people who are
listening slash watching to this care
about act so the value of act let's get
into the what of act what is act
can you break it down step by step how
does someone go through the process of
act
how does the person go through the
process of act well it depends it
depends which um
way you do it right so which treatment
delivery format
you're doing and so it could be
one-on-one therapy it could be workshops
it could be online you know okay i'll
give you an example for me i was dealing
with the obsessive thoughts that came
from rumination of
what the heck is reality and then
questioning my own
and then
i started to use one of the analogies
what's great about act is that it has
these visual analogies yeah so one of
them is thoughts as if they're
passengers on a bus and you're the
driver of the bus and if you were to
simply quiet the thoughts or tell them
to shut up or go away or be distressed
about them and place an undue amount of
attention to them then they become a bit
louder much like an obstreperous
audience member would become more
agitated the more that you speak to them
perhaps what you should do is simply
acknowledge their existence say oh i see
that you're there which is why by the
way i want to get to is acknowledgement
a better term than acceptance but we can
get to that later that's a very good
question
because accepting to me seems to take
those thoughts on and say oh no your
reality should be questioned and perhaps
so-and-so is not true so anyway that's a
very important question and i hope we
get to it we'll get to look at this
written down
and
so
then i would view those thoughts as
visually as passengers on a bus and i
would say okay well i'm going to direct
this bus where my values are and
initially i missed out on the values
portion so it wasn't as effective until
i because then where am i going with the
bus that to me is where the values come
in and why should i even go there so
initially i missed out on the value step
later when i added that it became more
effective for me okay so that's how it
worked
for me
and i think initially before that i was
doing something that didn't work which
you mentioned earlier thought
suppression i did i had a rubber band on
anytime i would have these thoughts that
would give me anxiety i would do the
self-administered adversive therapy
which i thought worked for thoughts and
it apparently it doesn't it rebounds
later maybe initially works but so i
stopped that and found act and then i
saw some success so that's my personal
case
with act so given that
that's what i mean can you take us
through an example of how someone
listening may employ this in their own
life and perhaps how one should apply it
in their own life is too broad and maybe
you just want to take a specific example
and say
you understand the question
so i'll start broad and maybe go a
little more narrow but tell me if this
is the wrong direction
so i'll share the
kind of key features right
first of all a rich and meaningful life
and act is about what you want
not what you don't want
it's about going for something that you
value and care about
rather than escaping from or avoiding
experiences that you don't want okay
and so for example
patients will come in or people will
come in and they'll say i don't want to
feel anxious anymore
i don't want to feel pain anymore i
don't want to feel sadness or guilt
anymore
people are quick
and automatically will tell you all the
things that they don't want
and
our medical field and in general our
society is like okay well don't
let's figure out how you can not feel
this way right let's figure out how you
can not feel this way think this way etc
act will say well okay
if you weren't in pain
what would you be doing instead
if this pain were not getting in the way
of living
as it is right now
what would you be doing
if you weren't so anxious
what would you be doing
right
if you weren't so guilt-ridden
what would you be doing you're trying to
get away from
symptom focus to
what do you want to be doing in your
life if those things were not there
so that's the first thing
then there's the issue of how to manage
emotions and thoughts
and our society has trained us to kind
of think
or to to respond to emotions and
thoughts that we don't like by pushing
them away
right if i tell my friend
i feel really anxious
what's the first thing they're going to
say kurt
about what
if i tell a friend i'm like
i'm sorry they may say what are you
anxious about
okay they might say what are you anxious
about and i'll say i'm really anxious
about giving this talk
then what what will they say
oh don't worry about it you'll do fine
you go girl
yep exactly don't feel anxious you're
fine right
don't worry about it you're fine it's
like so all the implicit messages we get
is don't feel that way right or if or if
i'm saying i feel really sad right now
don't feel sad it's going to be fine
right
we are taught even all the
advertisements about antidepressants
anxiolytics are you anxious are you sad
this can take it away
right this can take it away so we've
been programmed to think it's not okay
to feel this way
and so
the problem
is that both emotions
and thoughts things inside our body
that people cannot see
are mostly involuntary
these are mostly conditioned or
programmed responses
to certain circumstances in our life and
the idea in act is to simply notice them
for what they are
and not struggle against them so let me
give you two examples
number one if i say and i'm going to
give you a very benign one mary had a
little
lamb
one
red white and
i don't know this part blue
blue
one two
three
that's programmed
if i tell you kurt
do not say lamb
after mary had a little
could you not think lamb
could you do that
i mean i can't i don't know i imagine no
i imagine the answer is no okay mary had
a little think of something else
panda
okay
i'll come back to that you will always
always have lamb in your head
because our brain does not work by
subtraction
our brain works by addition
so trying to undo something is
impossible actually
if i told you right now
um a good friend of yours just got into
an accident
what would that trigger for you i feel
anxious
and
worried
could you undo that
i don't know some of the buddhists say
that with enough mindfulness training
one can get to a point where
stimuluses no longer provoke you at
least not to the same degree
i've seen some video online of a monk
self a lighting so setting oneself a
light it's calmly and then just dying i
don't know how the an extreme amount of
discipline
so
absolutely it's true
what you learn is
how to respond to these things in new
ways
it's not that they stop showing up
they still show up
but when they show up and you're not as
consumed by it
your attention is not so narrowly
focused on it
it doesn't have as much of an impact on
you right
so
if i'm
so i see this for example in a lot of my
pain patients or my chronic medical
condition patients like
their life has been so
fixated on the medical condition on the
pain on
you know getting things you know getting
the right meds getting this getting that
that they've lost track of the rest of
their life and they're depressed
they're not focused on their family as
much they're not focused on their career
as much they're not focused on things
that bring them joy
it's like they're narrowly fixated on
one aspect of their life which is the
condition or the illness or the
medical problem and i'm saying step back
and recognize that there is more to you
than that
but if this is the only part you're
going to fixate on of course it's going
to like consume you
and paradoxically occur
the more you open up your life
and do things like these patients with
medical conditions
when they stop fixating just on the
medical condition and start doing other
things again
paradoxically the pain goes down
it's the same thing with anxiety
when you start engaging in life more
and you allow the anxiety to be there
without it being kind of the thing that
drives whether you do something or not
paradoxically the anxiety goes down a
question that occurred to me is when you
were mentioning that you were feeling
anxiety and by the way i i'm extremely
nervous generally when i'm doing these
interviews as well
and also being interviewed for sure and
extreme oh my god i don't i generally
say no to people interviewing me so i
don't have as much courage as you
perhaps i should muster some what
occurred to me was does this technique
can i say something sure sure
perhaps you will choose to muster some
you don't have to do anything right it's
even that subtle comment about perhaps i
should
you don't have to do anything
do you choose to is there something
about it that matters to you in that
it's a very different experience to say
i have to do this versus
i'm choosing this
willingly
even if it's going to elicit anxiety in
me that's great that may help me in the
future or i may choose to allow that to
help me in the future i don't know
what's the right response to that but
regardless where i was getting it was
does this technique simply allow you to
cope or does it ameliorate the anxiety
because those are two different issues
yeah absolutely they are and um
that's the paradox of this
although act does not aim
to reduce symptoms
it's asking you to willingly sit with so
that's the term i use instead of
acceptance because i'll tell you why
if i'm willing to have the anxiety
that's instead of acceptance if i'm
willing
to have the anxiety
in service of something that matters to
me right
that's the goal the goal is me being
willing to experience something
difficult because it's in service of
something that matters
but when i do that repeatedly
paradoxically my anxiety goes down
it's not the goal the goal is not to
reduce my anxiety the goal is
for me to live a life that's meaningful
and rich
but what's paradoxical and what all the
research is showing
is that
when you do that
actually anxiety goes down
and i'll give you examples from my
studies because so i'm funded by the
national institutes of health and the va
department the veterans affairs
department
and nih and the va
for a long time has focused on symptom
reduction right so when i apply for
grants i say
i'm going to do this act intervention
and i'm going to explore whether this
reduces depression and anxiety
right i say that in the grant actually i
want to make sure
i reduce depression or anxiety
but when i'm actually in the treatment
actually doing the treatment i don't say
that ever
not once do i say
okay you know you guys met criteria for
depression which they all do
to be in the study for example and my
goal is for you not to meet criteria i
never
say anything about that
it's it's a
political decision it's a funding
decision that i put it as the outcome
but paradoxically the intervention even
though i never talk about reducing
anxiety and depression
i talk about helping them live a rich
and meaningful life and to let them
explore their emotions and not be afraid
of them but most of my studies i have
found
significant reductions in depression and
in anxiety and improvements in meaning
and purpose
is that too complicated no no so first
there are quite a few thoughts that
occur so one is we mentioned the eastern
approach this to me sounds like the
merging of the western approach of
bearing one's cross so it doesn't matter
that you're going to feel the suffering
you do it anyway because there's a
higher value
and then the other thought that occurs
to me is that it's extremely interesting
how often that happens in different
aspects of life where if your aim is to
reduce something or to attain something
you don't get it
but if you take a route where you're not
supposed to care about what you want you
end up getting it so for example with in
relationships if you desperately want
that person you try to please them you
end up not doing so and if you are in
business and you try to get money often
it doesn't work out you have to be
passionate about the product and so
it's just interesting how that works you
don't get what you want by trying to get
what you want
well i think what you're describing is
the difference between
being goal-oriented
versus value-oriented
right
let's say my goal is to get into medical
school
and i'm like i need to get into medical
school no matter what you know pressure
from family whatever it is like
that's a goal i can check it off the
list right
but what's the value behind that
is it to help people is it to you know
is it a selflessness thing what is the
value
behind
getting into medical school
and if you if you focus on that
then let's say you don't get into
medical school
right
then you say well what was the value
behind that was the value behind that
helping people
are there other ways that i can help
people there are many other ways that
you can help people right you can go to
pa school you can go to nursing school
you can join a non-profit that focuses
on these things
and so
when you're focused
when when your values are clear
then you're more about the process
you're more about the experience
versus if you're goal oriented you just
want to get there and check it off the
list
but then you check it off the list and
you're like well what's next
let me say in other words and let me
know if this is correct so that i make
sure that we're on the same page goal
versus values is akin to when sometimes
people say you shouldn't be
objective oriented versus process
oriented
is that akin to that or is that
different that's it's kind of similar
yeah it's kind of similar okay so that's
a great question right there are you
coming up with them are you realizing
them so are you making them
are you uncovering what was there anyway
that's a sub question that doesn't sound
like an easy process
so how can you help someone through that
process what tips do you have
for people to realize their own values
in the example you gave the
potential was that i want to help people
that's why i want to go to medical
school but it also may just be i want
the status but i think i want to help
people or i want the money but i think i
want to help people or actually this was
instilled in me as a child and it's
actually not my own i don't even care
but that takes to me that sounds like
that may take months or even years of
therapy so how does one streamline that
approach to get to one's values
that's a really good question and i
actually struggled with this
for a long time actually like
you know it seemed like such a broad
question to me like what are your values
well
it's tough right um and i remember like
having this aha moment you know
and
well there are many ways to get to it
but i had this aha moment
which broke down values into like
how do i want to be
in this moment
how do i want to be like okay i'm with
you right now kurt
so i check in with myself and i say
what do i want to be how do i want to be
in this moment with this person you know
so it makes it a little bit more
concrete to me you know
but it's also that but it also needs to
be a little bit more broad and i'll give
you a very personal example from my life
like
um so i'm
you know i'm a working mother
and
balancing my career with being the kind
of mother i want to be
can be very challenging you know
and so
for example i go to work let's say from
eight to five
and as i get up off my desk
um kurt
and i'm walking out the door right
there's a lot of anxiety
because
my colleagues are still there
i still have a lot of things on my to-do
list right i have a lot of things on my
to-do list
my career is very important to me
um and so when i get up at 5 00 p.m to
leave and all my colleagues are still
there and my boss is still there and i
still have a lot of things on my
checklist
i'm anxious
and
i connect with
the value of what i want to be as a mom
and i want to be a mom that's available
for a certain number of hours every
night
with few exceptions
because that matters to me
so i carry the anxiety i have about my
career but what helps me walk out the
door
is see is kind of knowing that my son is
on the other side right
so sometimes it's just a matter of like
you know filling out questionnaires or
like just you know people asking you
certain questions about what are your
priorities in life right
but i see a lot of people just
on automatic pilot right on automatic
pilot doing things like they always have
staying at work
long hours barely seeing their parent
you know their children
and they say
they say like for example the patient
that like works double shifts
then goes to the bar
takes out a picture of his children and
shows the people at the bar like here's
my child and love my child so so much
goes home hungover
and when the kid comes to talk to him
pushes him away like no no not now i'm
hungover
we can talk about what matters
right i can say
my son matters i can say
my parents matter to me
my sister matters to me
but if i don't put it into an action
it means nothing
it doesn't mean anything
and so
let me give you another example sure
kur if i asked you
if i said
there's a building on fire outside and i
want you to run into it
what would you say to me
no no
thank you you would say no appreciate
that
thanks for the offer yeah yeah
what if i said to you
a loved one you have is in that building
yeah
what would you say then yeah which loved
one but i understand yeah so if it's my
wife i'll go in in a second
okay
it shifted from an automatic no
to an automatic yes
because there was the why
the question is why would i go in there
what would be the purpose
and the purpose is your partner
right right
and so when you're is it going to be
easy is it going to be non-threatening
it's going to be awfully hard and it's
going to be life
threatening right
and yet you are willing
to experience
the fear the dread the anxiety that it's
going to take to get into that building
because there's something there that
matters to you
so that's
the acceptance piece acceptance is not
just saying oh okay i accept i accept
you know what i feel here
it's that i'm willing to feel what there
is as i move towards something that
scares me
earlier we had a little discussion about
should versus values and you were saying
kurt
well we didn't explicitly have this
discussion but you said perhaps
you shouldn't think in terms of should i
know that's paradoxical but you
understand what i mean that in terms of
thinking of choice it's better and i'm
unclear how values don't imply it should
so if you have a high value
to me a should comes in because it's
you're doing what's right now it's what
you're saying that the value is somehow
internal and the [ __ ] is somehow
external and it should come from should
it should come from you or
i it's a bit difficult for me to say
without using the word should so
hopefully you understand the question
i mean it could be just an issue of
linguistics right like it could be just
the terminology we're using but
values are freely chosen
from from an act perspective values are
freely chosen it's not what
our parents tell us
we should want it's not what i feel
society
wants me to say right
in the definition of values it is freely
chosen
and one indication
that
someone is not living a life
that's consistent with kind of what they
want
is there's a lack of vitality like you
don't sense vitality in what
someone is doing right
it feels more like it's
being imposed that it's like i have to
do this right or
i don't want to be doing this or you're
just not
you're not vitalized right
so back to my example with work
sometimes i feel like giving personal
examples helps if it's too much tell me
but like
no the more personal the better
you know every time i get really
frustrated with my job
with my work with my career
i step back and i ask
do i choose this no one's forcing me to
do this work i don't have to do this
work
do i choose this work
and that helps me a lot
with the full recognition that i choose
a package
that i can't just choose the things i
like
and
throw away the things i don't like
because everything we have in our life
is a package of
you know the things you like and then
the things that you have to do because
you know it's part of the broader
package
so maybe that's kind of what you're
talking about with this should like okay
doing this work i really have to write
certain notes and i have to like do all
this bureaucratic crap bureaucratic
stuff
that said do i choose the package
that this as a package
is something i care about
that working with these patients doing
this research makes this other tough
stuff worthwhile
interesting
one of the reasons i was bringing that
up is because
i know there's a heavy emphasis on an
internal locus of control it's called
internal locus of control i believe
and then that to me sounds like to get
philosophical like the humanist movement
and then
that stands in contrast to religious
movements especially of the west where
the west is more about there are some
commandments you should follow you need
to follow but then to many people their
religion is what they value so their
value comes with the shoulds in that
case and then are is one to say well if
you're christian or if you're
muslim or jewish because those are the
western traditions if you're those then
perhaps
you need to abandon your religion in
order to
properly apply act therapy so that you
have the internal locus of control it
comes from you it doesn't come from god
you choose it no i don't think that was
what was lurking underneath i don't
think so i think if you choose
a spiritual like a spiritual tradition
you're choosing that you're choosing the
package right it's like stepping
yeah again like you're you're talking
again about a very concrete thing that's
like more goal
like that okay so i'm going to church
check
right that's a goal i'm going to go to
church
check and goals can be very valuable to
like tell you if you're on the right
path
towards something you value right
but the broader value if someone is
you know maybe religious now some of
them are
of course some people are doing it out
of compliance right
absolutely
and then other people absolutely are
doing it because spirituality as a
broader
domain
is valuable and the specific
goal if you want or package that they
choose is
a christian or jewish or muslim right
like
the broader thing is that they are a
spiritual person and
that the goal they have is to fulfill
certain obligations within that
spiritual tradition it's like
me i love what i work or what i do
and as part of that i have to i
actually have to do certain things like
check you know i have to do certain
trainings i have to
fill certain cmes so on so forth some
bureaucratic it's the values part that's
that you don't have to
that you that that's chosen
the goals are the kind of the posts
along the way that you can say okay
check did that i know i'm on the right
track i understand yeah
what separates people
for who this works for
quickly or
plenty from those who
it takes a longer time to work for it
works less for is it their temperament
is it their attitude is it
the application of a certain technique
the amount that they stick with it for
example yeah
that's a really good question and i
think it's it's complex it's hard
because
for decades
in our field we have been trying to do
these matching studies right where okay
we're gonna match this kind of person
with this kind of therapy
you know um
like this person would do better with
this therapy this person would do better
with this therapy and
despite
millions of dollars being you know
committed to this kind of research
we don't really have a good answer to
that question not just for act but for
really a lot of the therapies like we
have not been able to figure out what's
what's the thing that
you know matches people like why would
this work for someone
that said
in the meta-analysis of the
meta-analysis of act studies and some of
the comparison studies
what we know or what we found is that
people who have
suffered longer
tend to do better in act
right
and people who have
complex
difficulties tend to do better with act
why do you think that is
it's a good question
so
my thought on this and i don't know that
there's any data behind this
in act there's a very key concept called
creative hopelessness
okay
and the idea behind creative
hopelessness is
okay like let's say you have anxiety
right
and i ask the person
who has anxiety
how long have you had this
and they'll say
15 years what have you tried
well i've tried alcohol
i've tried drugs i've tried medications
i've tried
avoiding
i've tried deep breathing
i've tried meditating like i've tried it
all
okay and how has that worked
um hasn't worked in terms of reducing
the anxiety
okay
and and how has it worked in terms of
like where you are with your life and
how big your life is
and they'll say
well maybe
it's it's really kind of gotten smaller
in my life
so what we do with creative hopelessness
is explore with the person
how long they've had the problem
all the techniques they've used
and if they've gotten anywhere with
these techniques in the long term
and
what what what the result is is the
patient being like oh my gosh i've been
doing this for
years and years and years and i'm worse
off than when i started
this it's called creative hopelessness
because
there's a hopelessness to it
but in that moment it gives you the
opportunity to say okay i think i need
to try something different
this has not worked
it's like it's like up in front of your
face that it has not been working you
know you've laid it out and that
everything you've been doing has not
been working
and so
the creative part is that there's this
pivotal moment
it can be a pivotal moment where and
i've seen it happen
countless times i see it in my
you know my participants my client's
eyes like there's a pivotal moment
that's like oh my gosh this is not
working
so i need to try something else right
for
this sometimes requires
a long time of suffering right like so
that's why sometimes i think it
resonates because
for some people they've tried for
example distraction and it's worked
temporarily and they've only had it for
a few months and they're good to go
so you know it's fine
but for people who've had it for a while
this resonates there's this pivotal
moment where they're like ah okay
okay it sounds like they've tried plenty
and then they're thinking well i need to
try something new but that something new
could be almost any of the therapies
that are tried and you said that act
seems to work better for these people
who have tried plenty already so what is
it because if it's this pivotal moment
then would that pivotal moment not apply
to any of the other therapies that that
they could try that are new any new
therapies i mean again act is
it tends to be equivalent to other gold
standard ah right right
so it's not i'm not saying it's better
and i'm not i'm not sure it's conclusive
that it's better for these people
but act is one of
it is the only therapy actually like
scientifically based one that's been
examined with you know randomized
controlled trials that has such a heavy
focus on the the values and it's it's
and it's also built on all these
you know basic science studies showing
that like thought suppression doesn't
work distraction doesn't work they come
in the rebound effect
but again the values piece is what
provides the motivation to to do the
hard work right so
the woman who has had panic attacks for
10 years and barely leaves her house
anymore
okay
and
has been to treatment and they've tried
to reduce the panic attacks
works for a bit not too long and she's
you know not leaving her house very much
anymore
her daughter is graduating
and this requires her to go
sit in a building with or in an
auditorium with hundreds of people like
the most stressful thing for someone
like this
what would motivate her to do this work
kurt
as her as her daughter is on the stage
and she looks up
into the seats
and she sees that her mother is there
right you make the values
front and center for the mom
do you want your daughter to see you
there
would you be willing to experience
that
feeling of overwhelming fear and anxiety
if it means that your daughter for the
rest of her life will say
my mom was there
so values make it worthwhile and it's a
really important aspect and so like a
lot of the traditional
cbt have now incorporated values into
their treatment models because we're
finding it's such a powerful piece right
but
values have always been the heart of act
have you
found any studies that demonstrate
whether act works for suicidal ideation
or other
i think you call them distressors before
or but i'm not sure other because we
don't want to call them illnesses but
other and nor do we want to call them
disorders per se but issues
other issues maybe psychosis
schizophrenia derealization
so
what's really interesting is
like i said there's over 300 randomized
control trials on act
and they range from mental health
conditions like depression anxiety
psychosis trichotillomania
there's a huge range of mental health
conditions
it's been effective in a huge range of
medical conditions diabetes multiple
sclerosis
cancer
cardio car um heart failure a lot of
those
hiv
and in terms of the outcomes are
different right it's like getting back
into care or
cancer-related anxiety or
okay just to be clear you're not saying
employ act in order to induce your
cancer to a state of remission
no it's like for things related to it
like cancer-related anxiety
or for in the in the heart failure
patients it's improving behaviors that
would
um improve actually your health
condition right
um migraines it's been helpful for
migraines because migraine is a very
similar condition right the more you
struggle that you're getting headaches
the more you're going to get headaches
and the more you avoid life because of
fear of getting headaches the more
sensitive you become to things that
trigger headaches
and also it's been used in a range of
life things like chest performance
stigma
prejudice
um rowing
so enhanced rowing sports rowing
enhancing sports performance for example
um
how about learning in general so for
example in this channel learning math
and physics
i don't know if i've seen a study on
that that doesn't mean it doesn't exist
um
could you imagine how it could be used
to enhance learning or would it just be
if some anxiety was holding you back
from learning we addressed that and then
the learning i think so i think it would
be more like
how do you become more present focused
when you're studying how do you you know
not let anxiety and difficult thoughts
get in the way because
you can overthink you can worry so much
that it gets in the way of how you do
so you would address that part of it you
know
like in the medical conditions we
address treatment adherence
with our diabetic patients for example
because patients don't want to think
about their condition they won't take
their medications because the
medications remind them of how sick they
are right it's an avoidance strategy
and so you're telling them to face
this thing that's scary to them because
actually in the long term
it will help them with their condition
right
so there's a lot of treatment adherence
things that act works on because a lot
of
difficulty with treatment adherence is
due to avoidance it's uncomfortable it's
inconvenient it's anxiety provoking
act has also been used in works
workplace stress and burnout among
medical professionals
um but you ask oh i know you asked me
about does it work for psychosis which
reminded me and now i'm jumping back
so act is listed as an empirically
supported treatment by
the american psychological association
and other
important boards for five conditions
for depression
anxiety
ocd
psychosis
and chronic pain
now it's been tested in
dozens of other conditions but to reach
the scientific rigor to be listed you
have to have a certain number of
clinical trials and they have to be from
independent labs and
you know so there has it's um
it's a very rigorous thing to get listed
on that but
imagine it's actually listed
as an empirically supported treatment
for psychosis
and so yes it works for that more in
terms of
not reducing symptoms per se
but learning to live
with them
more effectively and productively
in the first study of psychosis
act reduced rehospitalization
and getting back to the question of is
acknowledgement a better term than
acceptance because acceptance has the
connotation that you should accept the
thought like go with it
believe it even
so it's not what it should be called
it's what works right it's what works
that said
i don't use the term acceptance in my
work you know it's scientifically it
works you know when we're writing about
it
but in the like day-to-day interactions
with my patients or with my clients i
don't use the term acceptance because
it's a very loaded actually actually
term like they take it as like just suck
it up and accept it you know
and that's definitely not the intended
message
acknowledge is a much better term i
think
the thing that acknowledge
doesn't get into i think
although it might i just haven't thought
about it enough but
um
acknowledge is a really good one
i think what willingness does as an
extra step
is
connects it to the value because
are you willing
to feel this way
or to have these thoughts in service of
something important to you would you be
willing to experience fear and anxiety
if it means you'll be at your daughter's
graduation
would you be willing to experience all
the
difficulties
of graduate school if it means that
you'll get to do what you want to do at
the end right
so the willingness piece for me connects
it to the other side
which is a critical one
but certainly acknowledge is much more i
think compassionate than
accept
one of the questions i have and it's
more of a philosophical one is
determining whether
an issue is a psychological
problem or a physical one so for example
for me for a series of weeks i was
waking up
soon after going to sleep
terrorized by something by a dream and
feeling horror as they woke up and then
it turns out as soon as i started
sleeping on my side all of that went
away and it's because i have a mild
sleep apnea that i didn't know about and
this is common in people who have sleep
apnea your mouth your throat closes and
so you wake yourself up and because it
triggers a certain reflex you wake up in
fear and you think or i thought that i
need to go to see sigmund freud or carl
jung to resolve childhood issues that
are coming up in my dreams but it all
went away when i slept on my side
so that was a physical problem that i
thought was a psychological one so how
does one go about determining when a
problem requires a physical intervention
versus a psychological one so let's call
that question number one and then
a sub to that question one a is how does
one determine whether an intervention
such as running or exercise like a
physical one in this case that the lack
of it is the cause for the issue
versus the addition of it abates the
underlying problem so are those two
scenes the same
this is an ideological question so it's
more philosophical about
how does one determine whether the
presence of something
is the cure for the predicament versus
the lack of it being the cause of the
problem let me know if that was clear
because i can restate that
well
the question is a hard one and i won't
answer it directly what i will say is
that
mental health and physical health issues
are intertwined and
play a very strong bi-directional
effect on each other
so for example people who have when you
do longitudinal studies
people who have depression
are at much higher risk
for cardiovascular disease
and migraine and a range of physical
health problems
and the reverse is true
patients with migraine and
cardiovascular disease
ms
are at much higher risk for mental
health difficulties like depression and
anxiety
so
it's
they're very bi-directional and
longitudinal studies have shown this and
people have spent a lot of time trying
to figure out which comes first and
it differs for different people
i think the important thing to know is
that they do
influence each other you know
i'm not
sometimes targeting both as the best
strategy like let's take migraines right
stress
so migraines are triggered by many
things it's triggered by certain foods
it's
triggered by certain
changes in elevation
um
but it's one of the main triggers of
migraines is stress
right
so
if you address the stress
you might minimize the number of
migraines
that doesn't mean that migraines are not
a true neurological condition because it
is the brains
of patients with migraine
even outside of a migraine episode
their brains are different from people
who don't have migraines right
and so would that person benefit from
both
a preventive or acute migraine
medication and
stress relieving strategies
probably absolutely actually
same thing applies for cardiovascular
disease right
people who have depression are two times
more likely to die
from
cardiovascular than disease than people
without depression right is that the
cause
it's hard to say right but does it
impact it absolutely
so maybe that's a different way to
answer your question sure and can we end
on the visual just one more visual
exercise right one more visual well
there are many um
but one like the bus driver for example
that's very similar to the bus driver
but i do individually with my
patients it's called the lifeline you
know and i get and it's a physical one
in the sense that i stand next to them
and then i say something like
what is something that you really care
about that you haven't been doing
you know and
so maybe someone will say to me like i
want to go out more with friends but i'm
too anxious
and then i'll really get i'll say well
tell me why that matters to you you know
why
why do you even care about that
well because
you know i want to have friends and it's
important
and i really care about people
and so i'll i'll put a sticky note on a
door which is a little bit far away from
us you know
and i'll say what's one step that you
can take what's one small thing you can
do
that can move you closer to this
and
they might say something like
ask someone on a date or they might say
something like
say yes to an invitation right
and i'll say great and i'll put that
sticky on the door next to the value
like
want to have more social interactions i
want to ask someone on a date
so then i say okay
let's let's think about walking towards
that let's imagine that you're about to
go ask someone on a date
tell me what what shows up for you like
what thoughts pop up
like you're not good enough or you're
gonna look stupid
you're
you know not lovable enough like what
shows up
so i guide them but they start like
telling me some thoughts and i say okay
and what shows up in your body as you
think about going
to ask someone on a date
and they'll say oh like anxiety like my
heart's racing you know and so i'll
stick sticky notes
on their body that has all these things
like
heart racing
she's gonna reject you you're gonna look
like a loser
this is terrible i can't handle it right
but when you
write it out and it's like outside your
head and you're putting it on a sticky
note on their body
first of all you you're kind of
disentangling a little bit the monster
that comes as a flood
and then i ask the person to start
walking with me
towards that
sticky note that says what they want to
be doing
right
and as they are walking i start yelling
out all these things at them
you're going to blow it you're going to
be rejected it's going to be terrible
you're going to panic
and as i do that
i turn them around so that they stop
walking towards their value and start
walking away from it
and then i say how does it feel to walk
away from that thing that matters to you
they'll say it's a relief like because
i'm i stop i stop yelling at them as
well like their mind stops yelling at
them they've dodged a bullet
and i'll say okay
that's right
you've dodged a bullet
but what about that thing that matters
to you that thing that you really want
to do
and you'll be like well it's still far
away
right and i keep doing this
and like walking
and then turning him around walking and
like yelling these things that are on
the sticky note
and turning him around
until the last time or the final round
what i'll do is
i will walk with him all the way to the
sticky note have him grab the sticky
note
even though the thoughts are still there
right
he was willing to walk towards that
thing that mattered despite
all these difficult thoughts and
emotions that showed up
and then i'll say what does it feel like
to actually get there and they'll always
say like that feels like
more rewarding like i didn't let the
fear win i didn't let my mind win i
didn't let
my emotions win i i let the thing that
matters when
i like that so the reward the reward
trumps the relief
correct
interesting because of time constraints
the last three questions were answered
over email and so i'll read them aloud
here question number one how much of a
role does belief slash hope play in act
that is to say when a patient believes
quote unquote that the treatment will
work or hopes that the treatment will
work or trusts that the treatment will
work then i imagine it would increase
its efficacy lillian states the placebo
effect is a real thing
hope is an important aspect of change it
helps if a person has trust in the
provider and in the treatment for sure
question number two what about finding a
purpose slash thanking the negative
thought
understanding where it came from and its
reason and realizing it's not needed but
was trying to be helpful in its own way
for example saying to oneself yes i see
you anxiety and i understand how you're
trying to protect me when i was younger
that's how you came about but i'm still
going to ask that guy out on a date
anyhow
lillian answers yes this is something we
would do an act for sure our mind is
often trying to protect us so thanking
it and telling it where the thought
originated and that the context is now
different and that the thought is no
longer helpful is an act consistent move
the last question question number three
generally in studies one excludes people
with comorbidities because it
complicates the issues however it seems
like fewer and fewer people are those
who just have an isolated condition that
is to say greater and greater numbers of
people suffer from multiple issues
rather than just one thus these studies
don't necessarily reflect treatment
strategies that work for the majority of
people how does one overcome this flaw
that is not reflecting a patient's true
set of symptoms in the way studies are
designed
lillian answers most of my work has been
with people who have comorbidities
increasingly people are looking at
samples that generalize more to the
larger population
professor thank you so much i think
that's a great note to end on i think
that's extremely inspirational
great i'm glad
it was really nice to be here thank you
for inviting me i appreciate it i
appreciate you coming out and thank you
so much
pleasure take care
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you